you know I think what's going to happen
this year because of the economy is that
the places where the dollar goes further
going to be the hot places to go Central
and South America I think are really
going to grow in popular they're already
popular now bueno Cyrus is actually the
number for destination on our site which
is very surprising to me you know
because i think the dollar stretches so
far there and because there's so much to
offer the bang for your buck ecuador is
i think growing a popularity you know
everyone knows about the galapagos but
also mainland Ecuador has a lot to offer
there's you know jungles there's these
mountain highlands where they have these
beautiful haciendas that have turned
into hotels where you can go hiking and
fishing in that kind of thing Panama
Nicaragua Honduras again sort of the
adventure travel thing but also
beautiful beaches and diving and great
resorts starting to crop up there and
again great value for your box so you
know I think you're going to see a lot
of people talking about that you know
and and I guess the same is true at
places like Eastern Europe you know
country like macedonia the former in the
former Yugoslavia I'm Croatia hugely
popular amongst Europeans and Americans
are starting to discover it you know
it's sort of the alternative
Mediterranean you know people who've
been too nice and portofino and Greece
and all those places that you know are
in the eurozone very expensive and also
very familiar maybe looking for
something different that's a little less
discovered not overrun with Americans so
they're going to places like Croatia the
Turkish coast and then Romania which is
on the beach but you know as hiking and
skiing and similarly interesting
Paris in New York in London Tokyo Hawaii
you know those are all they all have
such assets that you can't take away
from them right i mean Paris has that
you know the beautiful street grid you
know a magnificent architecture great
food that which you know there's a lot
of Eve right i mean there's the cliche
right but you got to embrace it you got
to sit at a cafe and have a cup of
coffee and watch the world go by because
that's what you do in Paris interesting
Lee enough we we we did this it list
earlier this year the hot your
destination so we put Paris on it
because what we're seeing in Paris now
is you know Paris has always been sort
of trapped in amber you know it's the
same museums the same you know
restaurants are some style of food same
style of architecture has been prevalent
there for so long that it seems kind of
hidebound in a lot of ways but recently
there's been a change there so you're
seeing a lot of embrace of new design a
new architecture new styles of
restaurant is kind of an excitement I
don't know if it's the new president
that's sort of a friendly you know
friendly toward some Americans or
there's something going on in Paris
that's I think really exciting right now
well I think what's happening which is
interesting is you know like I said
about 10 years ago there was the whole
boutique hotel thing right so you know
smaller hotels that weren't run by big
chains that had quirkier personality had
interesting design you'd get more
personal attention from them because
they weren't you know 150 200 rooms they
were you know 75 or over 50 rooms what's
happened is the big corporations have
taken that concept and and co-opted it
so you're seeing hotels like W or high
it has a new thing called andaz which is
essentially the same thing as a W and
they've sort of corporatized that idea
and commoditize that idea so you know
don't get me wrong there's a great
hotels but they're not exactly the same
kind of individual personality hotels
that you saw 10 years ago so I think
what's happening now is that the
individual hotel owners are trying to
distinguish themselves in kind of a
retro way so you know the w's of the
world have a very contemporary design
they focus on you know cutting-edge art
they focus on big bustling bars and
restaurants that have a scene with a lot
of locals in it and I think you're
seeing a lot of hotel saying well we
don't want contemporary design we want
classic design and saying yeah we'll put
in a great restaurant it'll be fine
dining restaurant it won't be a big bar
scene at the restaurant and you know and
sort of return to sort of an old-school
service so they'll have Wi-Fi in the
rooms of course is everyone wants that
but also have butler service or they'll
have you know a more personalized
experience than you're going to get from
you know cookie cutter booty
you know any travel spot could be
romantic if you do it right you know
obviously Paris is a is a you know is an
obvious contender and it's just a
romantic place just to be in but have
any specific places that I would
recommend over any other you know
romance is one of those terms it's
really hard to nail down because it can
mean so many different things so many
different people you know to one person
romance is going whitewater rafting down
the you know the the Rio Grande and
another person you know romance is a
truffled you know risotto in a glass of
white wine with your you know your honey
right next to you and I don't have other
people romance is sitting on the beach
so yeah it's hard to it's hard to to
really nail that one down without
knowing more about what the person's
really right
yeah i think it's it's always fun to do
something you know like the signature
event like South by Southwest in Austin
or Mardi Gras in New Orleans Coachella
out in California you know it's a great
way to see a place and to meet other
people who are seeing that place but
it's not a great way necessarily to meet
locals sometimes so you know and and
this you know cities are transformed by
by events like that so you're not really
necessarily seeing the city at its best
audits and it's in the sort of normal
pace so you know to go to I don't know
Berlin during the Love Parade I mean
great party you know you apply see some
crazy stuff happening but you know
you're gonna see Berlin you know every
day Berlin and brilliant at its best
probably not traffic and you know a lot
of craziness going on so it depends on
why you're going but definitely a rise
in that kind of travel and people you
know sort of event or you know event
oriented trips have become more popular
because you know I think people are
trying to find more trying to derive
more reasons for them for their from
their trips you know they want to get
more out of everything they do and
that's a function of not having enough
time in your everyday life to you know
to not having off time your everyday
life so you you know every trip you take
you want to you know get as much out of
as you can
you know which it was an easy answer for
that it really comes down to researching
as much as you can about that place and
then making the decision that you're
comfortable making so you know for
example I wouldn't go to Kenya right now
it's just the situation is too volatile
it could all you know end up very
peaceful in the next couple of days or
could just descend into a very violent
situation more violent than it is now so
you know that's just my opinion they're
probably parts of Kenya that are
completely safe and there are probably
people going on safari there right now
having a fantastic time but you know
knowing what I know I wouldn't go on the
other hand i would go to Beirut in a
minute yes there's a risk that there's
going to be a bomb here or an
assassination there and riots all that
kind of stuff it's the Middle East these
things happen but look there are
hundreds and thousands well hundreds and
thousands of thousands of Europeans
going to Beirut all the time and they
don't get into any trouble so you know
one thing you can do you go to the State
Department's website and see what the
State Department has to say about a
destination but also go to some of the
other country governments websites so
the British Foreign Office has similar
warnings and information sheets on every
country and they tend to be a little bit
new more nuanced and a little bit more
detail than the American ones
Australia's are also a good resource so
you get a slightly different perspective
on things you know the American State
Department is you know it's a political
organization so even their travel
information is it has a slight political
tinge to us
yes there is and and you know I can't
really rattle you know do the right
thing don't you know don't rip off a you
know if you're in a market bargaining
for you know a trinket or something like
that don't get the guy down to the
absolute lowest price you can get them
down to you know you probably make ten
times as much as this guy does so so you
know let them have a little bit of a
profit right you know remember that as
Americans we are more privileged and
richer and better educated than most
people in the world and and remember
that that's a privilege and that and
that it's something that most people
else that we that we that we interact
with outside of the way outside of the
united states don't have and keep that
in the back of your mind that should
really guide the way you behave